there is a chance however miniscule you
think that chance might be the one day
you and I will meet and because I'm a
bit weird today I would like to prepare
you for our potential meeting
broadly speaking everybody on this
planet can fit into two different
personality types introverts and
extroverts extroverts the kind of people
who get their energy from being around
others from being social while
introverts are the kind of people who
recharge by being with themselves by
spending time alone I think that I'm
probably the most introverted person
that I know and this is coming from
someone whose friend group is made up
predominantly of people that I've met on
the internet so I'm pretty big one
pretty big introvert man the society
that we live in is one that for my mind
tends to favor people who are
extroverted and so I think it's pretty
normal for people when hearing the term
introvert to make a certain number of
assumptions for example that introverts
don't like people that they like to
spend all of their time alone that they
don't know how to communicate they are
rude that they don't know how to have
fun the list just goes on and I don't
blame people for making those kind of
assumptions about introverts because
that's just the world that we live in
but if we are going to meet I would feel
pretty bad if you came away thinking any
of those things about me so here is the
truth the truth about introverts
specifically me if when we meet I seem a
bit quiet it's not because I don't want
to talk to you it's just that as an
introvert I only ever feel the urge to
say words if I think I actually have
something valuable to add to a
conversation I would love to talk to you
I'm just not very good at initiating
conversation so it's probably safe that
you be the first person to say something
to me and that you bring up a topic
that's actually important I can't talk
for very long about the weather
but ask me about YouTube and I will not
be able to shut up on the topic of
talking in a controlled scenario like
this where I can take the time to think
about what it is that I want to say and
prepare it I like to consider myself as
being a pretty good communicator but if
you press me for an opinion that I
haven't had the chance to think about
yet I will inevitably flounder I will
miss words out of sentences mix them up
stutter and sometimes even give opinions
that I don't necessarily agree with just
so I can have something come out of my
mouth it's actually one of the reasons I
started the thing where I give I found
Charlie bad is two people who meet me in
person because I want to have something
prepared to say and do with people when
I meet them so sorry if I just don't
make sense sometimes I'm trying to get
in the habit of when I'm in a
conversation pausing and thinking about
what it is I want to say before I say it
but I haven't quite gotten the hang of
it just yet with all of this stuff
really there's no easy way to try and
fix any of it it's just how my brain is
wired in fact I think one of the worst
things that people can suggest is that I
have something wrong with me and need to
adjust my personality to be more like an
extroverted person I like being
introverted I like being quiet I like
being thoughtful I like spending time on
my own and I would hope that if we do
meet you will accept me for that social
awkwardness included now one of the
reasons I wanted to make this video
today is because this year at the third
annual VidCon I'm going to be doing a
little bit of an experiment and
attempting to meet as many people as I
possibly can one thing that I didn't
really enjoy about last year's VidCon
was that I spent the majority of it
hiding away in my hotel room planning
for my talk and not meeting people who
wanted to meet me and that wasn't very
fun or cool so this year I have booked a
booth on the VidCon floor and I'm going
to be sitting there for as much of
VidCon as I could possibly manage and
meeting as many people as I can which
will hopefully include you if you're
going and that's it so then it's a
mixture of the and end then you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool I just discovered
that I have a burp bottom just here you
ready then that is a good